.
* Der Hahn kräht. *
Schon als Kind
haben sie davon geträumt,
später einmal Tierarzt zu werden.
Nach einem fünfjährigen Studium
starten sie
mit viel Elan ins Berufsleben.
aber dann kommt der Alltag,
und bringt neben viel Freude
auch viele Schwierigkeiten
und Überraschungen mit sich.
Wir begleiteten
drei junge Tierärztinnen:
Alix spezialisiert sich zurzeit
in der Notfallstation des Tierspitals
in Bern in der Spitzentechnologie.
Mit ihrem Team
hat sie all die kritischen Fälle,
die täglich eingeliefert werden.
Im Kanton Waadt steht Florence
zwischen Rindern und Pferden
des Broye-Gebiets.
Es gibt viel Druck in der Bauernwelt,
aber Florence behält ihre Ruhe
und ihre gute Laune.
Nach ihrer Zeit
mit Kühen und Schafen im Jura
spezialisiert sich Eléonore jetzt
auf Kleintiere in Estavayer-le-Lac.
Hier hat sie
auch oft mit den Besitzern zu tun,
die ihre Tiere extrem gern haben.
Und das sind sie:
unsere jungen Tierärztinnen.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Morgens um 7 Uhr
ist Alix im Tierspital in Bern
schon auf ihrer
ersten Patientenrunde.
Guten Morgen, Lieber. Bravo!
Nach einer Nacht im Spital braucht
jedes Tier eine kleine Aufmunterung.
Geht's gut?
In einem Tagebuch von mir steht,
dass ich
schon als dreijähriges Mädchen
Tierärztin werden wollte.
Das ist heute immer noch so.
In Momenten des Zweifels
wollte ich Hundeführerin
bei der Feuerwehr werden.
Mein Papa sagte:
"Du kannst machen, was du willst."
"Aber zuerst machst du ein Diplom."
Das war ein guter Tipp, Papa.
Dieses Kätzchen
braucht besonders viel Liebe,
darum bleibt Alix
auch etwas länger bei ihm.
Salut, wie geht's dir? Ja ...
Diese Katze
hat einen Wirbel gebrochen
und kann darum auch
die Hinterbeine nicht mehr bewegen.
Du kannst auch nicht mehr
selbstständig urinieren.
Bei ihr ist die Prognose
leider überhaupt nicht gut.
Evtl. gibt es dieses Kätzchen
morgen schon nicht mehr.
Darum hätscheln wir
eine solch kleine Katze etwas,
damit sie sich nicht alleine
oder gelangweilt fühlt.
Ja, du bist eine Schöne.
Ich habe mit all meinen Patientinnen
eine enge Verbindung.
Es gibt solche,
die mir besonders am Herzen liegen.
Dann bleibe ich auch etwas länger.
Dann geht Alix ins Sprechzimmer.
Sie ist 30 und spezialisiert sich
auf Notfall- und Intensivmedizin.
Inzwischen ist es 8 Uhr
und der Spital öffnet.
Michel fuhr mit seiner französischen
Bulldogge extra von Genf hierher.
Hier noch den Namen des Hundes.
Und hier noch Ihren Namen.
Olive ist etwas scheu.
Er ist ein Charmeur.
Und von diesem Charmeur will sich
Michel absolut nicht trennen.
Grüezi,
ich würde den Hund gleich mitnehmen.
Nein, nein, das mache ich schon.
In die Notaufnahme
dürfen Sie nicht mitkommen.
Dann warte ich dort eben.
Den Hund in diesem Zustand
alleine lassen,
kommt für Michel nicht infrage.
Über 1 1/2 Std. fuhr er auf Anraten
seines Tierarztes hierher.
Olive hat nämlich starke Atemnot.
Gestern ging es ihm
bereits nicht gut.
Heute Nacht bekam er
immer mehr Probleme mit dem Atmen.
Ich habe darum
auch nicht viel geschlafen.
Die Atmungsprobleme
könnten auch etwas Schlimmes sein,
darum muss es jetzt schnell gehen.
Grüezi, ich bin die Assistenzärztin.
Grüezi.- Sie können gleich
mit mir kommen.Ist das gut so?
Bis zur Türe darf ich?
- Genau.
Wieso darf ich nicht mit hinein?
Drinnen wird ein anderer Notfall
untersucht, eine Katze.
Dann passen wir
wegen den Keimen genauer auf.
Ein Hund
hat genauso Panik wie der Mensch.
Wenn also jemand bei ihm ist,
den er kennt, geht es ihm besser.
Die einfache Psychologie zählt,
nicht wahr?
Das ist wie bei den Ärzten,
genau gleich.
Bitte?- Wie bei den Ärzten
für Zweibeiner, meine ich.
Dort trennt man die Patienten
auch von ihren Angehörigen.
Michel stellt den Fuss in die Tür.
Er will unbedingt mit hinein.
Sehen Sie die Katze?
Das ist der Grund.
Kann ich nicht mit hineinkommen?
Wegen Ihren Kleidern leider nicht.
- Meine Kleider?
Ja, es tut mir leid. Sonst müssen
Sie wieder zum Empfang gehen.
Das ist jetzt aber nicht normal, das
ist nicht normal.- Wie Sie wollen.
Früher konnte man
beim Tierarzt bleiben.
Heute werden die Tiere
wegen der Hygiene,
den Bakterien usw. separiert.
Michel gibt nicht auf.
Gut.- Ein Tier muss beim Mensch
sein, damit es sich wohlfühlt.
Ich komme gleich mit der Ärztin.
Sie kann Ihnen das
vielleicht besser erklären.- Jaja.
Sie bringt Michel in ein Sprechzimmer
und bittet Alix um Hilfe.
Könnten Sie mit dem Besitzer
sprechen?- Nein.
Alix ist mit einem anderen Notfall
beschäftigt.
Die Assistentin
wird langsam ungeduldig.
Es ist Zeit, um etwas zu tun.
Atemnot, aber ja.- Sie hat
ihn aufgenommen, nicht wahr?
Er atmet schlecht.
Ich kann nicht warten.-Gut.
Darum fragt sie einen anderen
Tierarzt, ob er Michel erklärt,
was mit seinem Hund los ist.
Meine Kollegin ...- Es bleibt mir
ja nichts anderes übrig.
Aber für ihn ist es besser.
Das wissen Sie, oder?
Das ist mir schon klar,
aber für mich ist es nicht gut.
Das richtet sich nicht gegen Sie,
sondern gegen das System.
Das vertrage ich nicht. Ich streite
jedes Mal mit den Tierärzten.
Manchmal gebe ich nicht nach,
hier schon, wegen dem Hund.
Es ist Michel sehr zuwider,
seinen Hund den Ärzten zu überlassen.
Dabei tickt für Olive die Uhr.
Das kann gefährlich werden.
Meine Kollegin nimmt den Hund mit
und bringt Ihnen dann die
richtigen Formulare. Vielen Dank.
(Mürrisch)
Ich habe nichts zu danken.
Michel lässt sich nicht besänftigen.
Schliesslich
geht er trotzdem ins Wartezimmer.
Dort hält er es vor Ungeduld
fast nicht aus.
Endlich kann Olive untersucht werden.
Das Notfallteam
gibt ihm zuerst Sauerstoff
und Alix macht erste Abtastungen.
Soweit wir feststellen,
ist die Atmung sehr schnell.
Wir wissen von seinem Tierarzt,
dass er Flüssigkeit im Bauchraum
festgestellt hat.
Das sieht man
an seinem gespannten Bauch.
Das hier ist alles Flüssigkeit,
die das Tier im Bauchraum hat -
Bauchwassersucht.
Und äh ...
das ist natürlich nicht normal.
Das Bauchwasser
drückt auf die Organe -
massiver Abdomenerguss
für das kleine Tier.
Hier unter dem Halsband
kann man den Puls spüren.
Auf dieser Höhe,
das ist auch nicht normal.
Das könnte ein Herzproblem sein.
Aber zur Sicherheit müssen wir
noch ein paar Untersuchungen machen.
Die Untersuchungen
kann man nur machen,
wenn der Besitzer einverstanden ist.
Er ist  verantwortlich und
er muss für die Kosten aufkommen.
Grüezi, ich bin die Tierärztin.
Ich erkläre Ihnen, was wir machen.
Ihr Hund bleibt im Moment im
Notfall, dort bekommt er Sauerstoff.
Dort können Sie leider nicht hinein.
So sind unsere Hygienevorschriften.
Darum tragen wir Kittel,
damit wir keine Keime hineintragen.
Sie können beruhigt sein,
es geht ihm gut.
Er ist eben ein Charmeur.
- Ja, er ist ein Herziger.
Am Anfang
bin ich immer misstrauisch.
Zuerst muss mir die andere Person
zeigen, dass ich ihr vertrauen kann.
Sie können ja
schöne Sachen erzählen -
etwas Streicheltherapie
wie sie sagen.
Vielleicht sind sie ja wirklich
nett. Das könnte ja sein.
Sie können sich hier setzen.
Das gehört zum Service.
Dann eben.
Wir versuchen, zu den Leuten
einen guten Draht zu finden.
Wir wissen,
dass der Besitzer gestresst ist.
Man wird manchmal etwas ungehalten,
wenn etwas anders läuft
als man will.
Auch, weil man nicht immer
alles versteht, was wir tun.
Aber wir können uns
auch nicht alles gefallen lassen.
Wenn wir Schwäche zeigen, zweifelt
der Besitzer an unseren Fähigkeiten,
v.a. weil wir noch jung sind.
Manchmal fragen sie uns,
ob wir schon doktoriert hätten.
Dann muss man ruhig bleiben
und klar kommunizieren,
dass wir wissen, was wir machen -
auf eine seriöse Art.
Dann geht es meistens gut.
Es ist ernst.
Und wir sind nicht sicher,
wie er auf die Behandlung reagiert.
Es ist einfach wichtig, dass das in
einem vernünftigen Rahmen geschieht.
Dann sehen wir,
ob er darauf anspricht.
Ich möchte einfach wissen, was ihm
fehlt, damit ich abwägen kann ...
D.h., eine Behandlung für 4'000
oder 5'000 Fr. liegt nicht drin,
wenn man ihn am Schluss
dann doch einschläfern muss.
Oder man gibt ihm nur noch
ein paar wenige Monate zu leben.
Das muss man sich schon überlegen.
Um ihre Diagnose zu bestätigen,
braucht Alix eine Blutanalyse
und eine Ultraschalluntersuchung
des Herzen.
Einfach ist es sicher
nicht mit Michel.
Die Tierärzte, die neue Generation -
das ist wie bei den Menschen,
die medizinisch, technokratische ...
Man macht keine Diagnose mehr.
Eigentlich sind es Maschinen, die
die Diagnose machen.- Es wird ...
Ich kannte noch Tierärzte, die noch
eine Diagnose stellen konnten.
Klar, Ihr Tierarzt ...
Michel hackt weiter auf Alix herum.
Sie lässt sich
nicht einschüchtern.
Es geht ums Herz.
Wir könnten Medikamente geben,
die evtl. etwas nützen.
Wenn es nicht angepasst ist,
hilft es Ihrem Hund nichts.
Nein, nein, er ist ...
- Sie sind nicht überzeugt ...
Es sieht aus,
als wäre die Sache geklärt.
Jetzt kommt noch
das leidige Thema Geld.
Es ist wie bei den Menschen:
Jetzt geht es ums Geld.- Genau.
Ich habe es ja immer gesagt.
Ich bin eben ein alter Fuchs.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Das ist okay.
Solange der Hund lieb ist,
ist das okay.
Und Charme hat er sowieso.
- So ist es.
Das ist recht teuer.
Es kostet 1'500 - 2'000 Fr.
Eine rechte Summe!
Aber Michel zögert keine Sekunde.
So, voilà!
Möchten Sie ihn noch einmal sehen,
bevor Sie nach Hause gehen?- Ja.
Es ist so, dass wir
noch eine Anzahlung brauchen.
(Lacht) Kommen wir also noch dazu.
Normalerweise ...
- Die Hälfte?
Im Normalfall ja. Das wären 700 Fr.
- Zuerst gehen wir zum Hund.
Selbstverständlich.
- Bevor ich 700 Fr. bezahle.
Alix weiss, wie schwierig
es für einen Hundebesitzer ist,
seinen Hund im Spital zu lassen.
Grüezi, die Damen!
Darum schmeichelt
sie nicht nur mit Olive,
sondern umschmeichelt auch Michel.
Übrigens, Streicheleinheiten
sind im Preis inbegriffen.
Ah ja, die muss man bezahlen.
Wie viel wollen Sie dafür?
- Das ist inklusive.
Das ist im Preis für
den Spitalaufenthalt inbegriffen.
Das ist
schon in der Anzahlung inbegriffen.
Nein, nein, Sie machen es hier gut.
Wir machen das.
- Auf jeden Fall jetzt vor mir.
Nein, ich mache einen Witz.
Wir wollen ja nicht, dass die Tiere
im Spital traumatisiert werden.
Geben wir nur eine Spritze,
würden sie es.
Darum streicheln wir sie, auch
wenn es nicht wie zu Hause ist.
Michel ist zufrieden,
aber er merkt einfach alles.
Er ist hier im Notfall -
in seinen Strassenkleidern.
Um mich zu verabschieden,
liessen sie mich ja auch rein.
Das zeigt doch genau,
dass die Veterinäre
eine gewisse Macht ausüben.
Sie haben die Macht,
mit dem Tier alleine zu sein
und intern zu diskutieren.
Niemand soll ihnen dabei zuhören.
Aber ich war dort drin ohne Kittel.
Noch einmal Tschau sagen ...
Mach's gut.
- Ich vergesse Sie nicht.
... und noch einmal ein Küsschen.
Bis später.
Und dann geht Michel
schweren Herzens.
Also, adieu!
In Estavayer-le-Lac
beginnt für Eléonore ein neuer Tag.
Hu!
Éléonore arbeitete früher im Jura
und hatte v.a. mit Kühen zu tun.
Jetzt will sie sich
auf Kleitiere spezialisieren.
* Lockere Klänge *
Hoi, Kiwi!
In dieser Branche der Tiermedizin
muss man sich recht anpassen können.
Kiwi, komm!
Let's go, let's go!
Kleintierhalter haben eine andere
Beziehung zu ihren Tieren als Bauern
Bei einem Bauern ist das Tier
auch eine Einkommensquelle.
Haustiere hingegen
sind Familienmitglieder.
Das ist wie ein Kind zu pflegen.
Darum kann ich hier
nicht wie mit einer Kuh umgehen.
Kiwi, bist du an den Füssen kitzlig?
Ja?
Man muss anders sprechen
als auf dem Bauernhof.
Meistens kommt die ganze Familie
mit, wenn das Hündchen geimpft wird.
Die Eltern, die Kinder -
alle kommen mit.
Das ist schon eine andere Beziehung.
Eléonore macht bei Kiwi
eine Routineuntersuchung.
Und schon klingelt wieder
das Telefon.
* Klingeln *
Eine junge Frau sucht einen Tierarzt
für eines ihrer Hühner.
Grüezi!
Araceli wohnt in Frasses
im Kanton Fribourg.
Schon frühmorgens
steht sie im Hühnerhof
und verhätschelt ihre Seidenhühner.
Sie züchtet sie auch selber
und nimmt an Wettbewerben teil.
Es sind zwar Hühner,
aber wenn ich zu ihnen gehe,
dann rennen sie immer auf mich zu.
Sie kennen mich.
* Gackern *
Sie sind sehr zutraulich,
total neugierig,
und wenn man ihnen zuschaut
sehr lustig.
Sie sind herrlich, herrlich!
* Aufgeregtes Gackern *
Überwachungskameras, Elektrozaun -
das Gehege ist absolut sicher.
Aber dieses Mal
kam die Gefahr von oben.
Gestern Abend hat sich
ein Bussard auf Claudette gestürzt
und sie schlimm zugerichtet.
Dort hinten war sie
und der Bussard hockte auf ihr.
Er hat sie richtiggehend gerupft.
Ich rief meinen Mann:
"Komm schnell!"
"Ein Bussard
hackt auf mein Huhn ein."
Als der Bussard uns sah,
flog er davon.
Erst als ich Claudette aufnahm,
sah ich, wie schlimm es ist.
Zuerst wollt Araceli
nicht den Tierarzt anrufen.
Doch am anderen Morgen fährt sie doch
sehr früh in die Tierpraxis.
Sie möchte ihre Claudette retten.
Sie ist eines
ihrer besten Wettbewerbstiere.
Grüezi, Frau Vésy.
- Grüezi.
Wie geht's? - Gut und Ihnen?- Jaja.
- Sie kommen mit einem Huhn.- Ja.
Haushühner sehen wir
eher selten in der Praxis.
Das ist ein Tier,
das sehr anhänglich sein kann.
Es kann einem
genauso viel Freude bereiten,
wie ein Hund oder eine Katze, darum
behandeln wie es genau gleich gut.
Was ist ihr passiert?
Sie wurde gestern
von einem Bussard angegriffen.
Oh!
Ich ging zu ihr, aber erst
ca. 15 Min. später - leider.
Sie hatte eine grosse Wunde
auf der Höhe der Schulter.
Wir haben die Knochen gesehen.
Das war krass.
Schauen wir uns das an.
Die Frage ist, ob er gebrochen ist.
Die Verletzung am Flügel
fiel uns zuerst auf,
weil man die Flügelmuskeln sah.
Ich spüre nichts, das gebrochen ist.
Die Wunde ist offen. Wir müssen sie
betäuben und hier aufschneiden.
Und dann wieder zusammennähen.
Aber mir macht v.a., schauen Sie,
der Hals Sorgen.
Als ich das Genick sah,
wusste ich relativ schnell,
dass man das
sicher nicht nähen kann.
Es fehlt ein grosses Stück Haut.
Ich denke,
das hat der Bussard genommen.
Darum lagen alle Nackenmuskeln
des Huhns völlig frei.
Man kann sie nicht zudecken.
Auch mit Antibiotika
würde sich das entzünden.
V.a. muss es wahnsinnig weh tun.
Es ist schon mehr als 12 Std. her,
seit es passiert ist.
Offene Wunden sollte man
möglichst schnell schliessen.
Das ist wichtig,
damit es keine Infektionen gibt.
Hier ist schon zu viel Zeit vorbei.
Das gibt eine Blutvergiftung.
Daran wird sie sterben.
Die Bakterien vermehren sich, gehen
ins Blut und das Tier stirbt.
Sie ist jetzt schon recht ...
Nicht wahr, Schätzchen.
Was würden Sie mir raten?
Schauen Sie, medizinisch gesehen,
kann man immer etwas machen.
Wenn ich an das Tierwohl denke ...
Ehrlich gesagt ...
Ich nehme mit ihr an Wettbewerben
teil. Darum ...- Verständlich.
Sich von Claudette zu trennen,
kommt nicht infrage.
Schliesslich hat sie
mehrere Wettbewerbe gewonnen.
Zuerst wollte ich nicht,
weil ich dachte,
man könne versuchen, sie zu heilen.
Ich hätte gerne
noch ein paar Tage gewartet.
Auch wenn wir etwas machen,
kann ich Ihnen nicht garantieren,
dass das Huhn nicht leidet.
Es wird sehr leiden.
Das macht es jetzt schon.
Es ist nicht einfach,
die Besitzerin davon zu überzeugen,
dass das Huhn grosse Schmerzen hat,
auch wenn man es nicht sieht.
Bei einem Tier, weiss man nicht, ob
es leidet. Es kann ja nichts sagen.
Katzen oder Hunde können jammern,
aber ein Huhn ... Das sagt nichts.
Ich glaube, sie leidet schon sehr,
darum bewegt sie sich nicht.
Ich glaube,
dass Huhn hatte einen Schock.
Es hat entsetzlich gelitten,
darum war es so still.
Araceli ist wie betäubt.
Es braucht einen Moment bis sie
realisiert, was das bedeutet.
Eléonore muss ihre Worte sehr genau
wählen und darf nichts überstürzen.
Sie raten mir also,
sie einzuschläfern?
Ich würde sagen, für das Huhn
ist es sicher das Beste.
Die Wunde ist zu gross zum Nähen.
Hier sehen Sie es. Rein chirurgisch
kann ich nichts mehr machen.
Sie ist zu gross.
Und dann noch etwas,
das man gerne vergisst:
In dieser Jahreszeit gibt es
viele Fliegen.- Ja, das auch noch.
Wenn Fliegen dran kommen,
dann ist es aus.
Das Problem ist,
dass in der Sommersaison die Fliegen
überall Eier legen.
Es reicht, wenn nur
eine Fliege auf die Wunde sitzt
und dort ihre Eier ablegt.
In ein paar Stunden
wird dann das Tier
von den Maden lebendig aufgefressen.
Okay.
Wenn es nicht anders geht, müssen
wir sie eben töten, einschläfern.
Für das Huhn ist es sicher
die vernünftigste Lösung.- Okay.
Hier beginnt das Gewebe
bereits abzusterben.
Nein, das geht nicht.
Es tut mir leid.
Aber trotzdem danke.
Ich hätte schon gerne gehabt,
dass sie sie retten kann.
Wenn es nicht geht, geht es nicht.
Sie kann nichts dafür.
So sind die Schmerzen schneller weg.
Das ist besser für das Tier,
schlechter für den Besitzer,
aber eben ...
Einer Besitzerin, die offensichtlich
an ihrem Tier hängt,
ist es nicht einfach, zu sagen,
dass man ...
... dass man ihr Tier töten muss  -
nicht einfach.
Ich hätte sie
gerne wieder mitgenommen.
Das verstehe ich gut.
Es ist nicht einfach,
Claudette hier zu lassen.
Noch einmal streicheln.
Es ist nur ein Huhn,
aber ich hänge trotzdem an ihm.
Das ist normal.
Es ist ein Lebewesen.
Mit der Zeit
entwickelt man Gefühle dafür.
Ein Tier - man liebt es einfach.
Es ist hart, sehr hart.
Okay, kann ich sie hierlassen?
- Ja, Sie können sie hierlassen.
Vielen Dank.
- Kein Problem.
Bis ... Ich hoffe nicht ...
- Nein, lieber nicht.
Also ...- Adieu. Einen guten Tag.
- Adieu miteinander.
Beim Einschläfern
will sie nicht dabei sein.
Diese Aufgabe
muss Eléonore alleine durchziehen.
Wir probieren es einmal mit zehn.
Ich weiss, dass Vögel
manchmal anders reagieren.
Achtung, dein Finger!
Hier hat es einen Knochen.
Ruhig, ganz ruhig!
Es ist nicht einfach ein Huhn.
Es ist ein Lebewesen.
Klar, man hat jedes Mal Skrupel.
Man denkt immer, ob es nicht
noch eine Lösung gegeben hätte.
Es ist nie eine leichte
Entscheidung - überhaupt nicht.
In Lilis Händen
schläft Claudette friedlich ein.
Jetzt einfach hinlegen -
ganz vorsichtig.
Und dann kommt trotzdem
noch eine Überraschung.
Ah, da sind sie.
Es krabbelt schon.
In zwei Tagen
sind sie so gross wie Reiskörner
und fressen in der offenen Wunde.
Das haben sie gerne.
Sie fressen das Tier
bei lebendigem Leib auf -
von innen nach aussen.
Ah, ja.
Zum Glück kam die Besitzerin
recht schnell zu uns,
um das Schlimmste zu verhindern.
Die Fliegenlarven
fressen sich in den Tierkörper.
Zum Glück haben wir ihr das erspart.
Eléonore stellt Claudettes Tod fest.
Sie ist froh, dass das Tier
nicht mehr leiden muss.
Ich bin erleichtert, dass das Tier
nicht mehr länger leiden musste.
Aber auch etwas frustriert,
schlussendlich ...
Ja, weil ich heute
dem Tier das Leben nehmen musste.
Das macht einem oft leer.
Manchmal müssen wir sogar an einem
Tag ein paar Mal Tiere einschläfern.
Leer - leer ist das richtige Wort.
Man hat keine richtige Kraft mehr,
um zu kämpfen.
Am nächsten Tag steht man auf
und man macht weiter.
Man startet immer wieder neu.
* Sanfte, akzentuierte Klänge *
Eine weite Landschaft und viel Vieh.
In diesem Umfeld fühlt sich
die 27-jährige Florence wohl.
Sie arbeitet seit dem
Studienabschluss als Landtierärztin.
Perfekt!
Die Leidenschaft für ihren Beruf
wurde ihr schon in die Wiege gelegt.
Ihr Vater ist Tierarzt
und die Grosseltern sind Bauern.
Als ich klein war, hatte ich
ca. 100 Kaninchen und 30 Schafe,
und einen Hühnerhof,
um den ich mich kümmerte.
Ich habe also früh gelernt,
wie man mit ihnen umgeht.
Ja, warte Schätzchen, ja, ja!
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
die Tiere verstehen mich besser
als gewisse Menschen.
Ich habe ein Feeling für sie,
ohne zu wissen weshalb.
Darum machte ich aus
meiner Leidenschaft meinen Beruf.
Bist du süss.
Florence ist auf dem Weg zu
einem Landwirtpaar nach Grandsivaz.
Diese verwöhnen ihre Tiere gerne.
Jean-Daniel und Gisèle
leben alleine auf ihrem Hof.
Ihre Kühe kalbern alle
ungefähr zur selben Zeit.
So sind in sechs Wochen gut
60 Kälbchen auf die Welt gekommen.
Die beiden kommen kaum mehr nach.
Ich würde sagen,
in dieser Zeit sind wir ...
Wie lange?
Etwa 10 Std. pro Tag im Stall.
Mindestens, wenn es gut geht.
Sie machen sich Sorgen um
das Kälbchen, das eine Woche alt ist
und nicht mehr aufstehen will.
Es hat vermutlich
eine Infektion erwischt.
Es war oft draussen, auch bei Regen.
Ich glaube, das könnte
eine Lungenentzündung sein.
Kälbchen sind genauso anfällig
für Grippe wie wir Menschen.
Sie können genauso gut
einen Schnupfen erwischen.
Als wir sahen,
dass es ihm nicht gut geht,
haben wir es, zusammen mit der
Mutter, von den anderen getrennt.
Bei 60 Geburten gibt es immer
ein paar kranke Kälber.
Guten Tag!
- Grüezi!
Die Besuche der Tierärztin
häufen sich.
Fieber habe ich noch nicht gemessen.
- Das mache ich gleich.
Es ist auch unterkühlt.
Es ist kalt.
So, Schätzchen.
Hier hat es
noch eine kleine Infektion.
Hier ist es feucht.- Oh ja,
das habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Als ich den Bauchnabel sah,
bin ich erschrocken.
Er war vereitert und sehr entzündet.
Beim Abkalben
muss man gut darauf achten,
dass der Bauchnabel schön abtrocknet
und sich nicht entzündet.
Der Nabel ist für viele Bakterien
der Hauptzugang in den Körper.
Dort können sie sich
schnell verbreiten.
Das kann schlimme Folgen haben.
Die Lunge rasselt etwas.
Auf der Lunge?
- Ich höre hier noch einmal.
Und im Kot hat es Blut?
Das volle Programm.
Wir stellen es auf die Beine,
und schauen, wie es läuft.
Also, hoppla! Sehr gut.
- Es schwankt.
Es läuft ein wenig im Zickzack.
- Wie ein Krebs.
Geh dort hin!
Der schwankende Gang ist ein Zeichen
für eine metabolische Azidose.
D.h., das Blut ist übersäuert,
und darum ist das Kalb wie gelähmt.
Wir müssen eine Infusion machen.
Es ist komplett übersäuert.
Bei stark übersäuertem Blut kann es
dem Kalb sehr schnell schlecht gehen.
Die Infusion wird das Säure-Basen-
Verhältnis im Blut ausgleichen.
Und es braucht auch noch Antibiotika.
Voilà, dann hole ich das Material.
Okay, also du.
Ist gut. Komm nur, komm näher!
Eine Kuh wird langsam unruhig.
Es ist die Mutter,
die ihr Junges schützen will.
Nachher kannst du kommen.
Gisèle versucht,
ihre Kuh zu beruhigen.
Ja, du kannst es
nachher wieder haben.
* Muhen *
Wenn die Mutter hier drin wäre,
könnten wir das Kalb nicht behan-
deln. Das würde sie nie zulassen.
Wir könnten nicht ins Gehege.
Zusammen im Gehege? Nein, nein,
wir wären sicher nicht geblieben.
Sie hätte uns gleich hinausgeworfen.
- Oh, ja.
Sicher.
- Genau.
Die Schwarze hätte uns
im hohem Bogen rausgeworfen.
* Muhen *
Ah, sie lief rundherum.
Die Mutter?
- Ja. Zuerst war sie dort drüben.
Sie sucht ihr Junges.
- Ja.
Mich hat einmal eine Mutterkuh
auf die Hörner genommen
und mich übel zugerichtet.
Darum ...
Ich habe ihr Kälbchen untersucht
und die Mutter hat mich angegriffen.
Ich dachte wirklich,
dass ich sterbe.
Ich war lange im Spital.
Jetzt bin ich vorsichtiger.
Zuerst die Infusion?
- Ja.
Es läuft noch nicht recht.
Sie hat keine Blasen.
Es ist nicht einfach,
bei diesem dehydrierten Kalb
eine Vene zu finden.
Nein, das gefällt mir nicht.
Wir drehen es um.
Während Florence
auf die andere Seite geht,
beruhigt Jean-Daniel die Mutterkuh,
die Florence
nicht aus den Augen lässt.
* Muhen *
Aber ja.
Die zugeführte Flüssigkeit
gibt dem Kalb bereits Kraft
und es beginnt auszuschlagen.
Nein, das kannst du
jetzt nicht machen!
Pst!
Jetzt haben wir es.
Oh, komm, steh auf!
Du weisst, dass deine Mutter kommt.
Noch etwas unsicher auf den Beinen,
sucht das Kälbchen seine Mutter.
Wo ist sie?
- Komm, ich helfe dir.
Komm!
Giesèle ist es gewohnt,
mit ihren Kühen zu sprechen.
Offensichtlich funktioniert es.
Dort drüben ist es.
Genau dort. Schau dort!
Also.
Ich spreche gerne mit ihnen.
Sie verstehen mich nämlich schon.
Es ist wahr, sie verstehen mich.
Sie verstehen die Bauernsprache.
- Genau.
Nach dem Energieschub
hat das Kalb seine Reflexe wieder
und sucht die Zitzen seiner Mutter.
Wir sahen,
dass es sofort getrunken hat,
damit es wieder zu Kräften kommt.
Es ist schon unter ihr.
Ich glaube, es funktioniert.
- Ja, es saugt.
Ja, es ist unter ihr.
Es trinkt sie gleich leer.
Man sieht, dass Gisèle
und Jean-Daniel Freude haben.
Jetzt ist alles wieder gut.
Florence muss nicht mehr kommen.
Das Kälbchen erholt sich bald
von seiner Infektion.
Dieser Zaun hält einem fit.
Also, adieu!
- (Scherzend) Bis nie mehr!
Ade. Wir haben uns in diesen Tagen
oft gesehen, nicht wahr?
Adieu, einen schönen Tag!
* Vogelgezwitscher *
Im Tierspital in Bern
verabschiedet sich Alix von Michel.
Der aufsässige Hundebesitzer kann
einfach seinen Mund nicht halten.
Ich schau nach.
- Bis später, adieu!
Jetzt bekommt er Schläge.
- Nein, nein.
Streicheln inbegriffen?
Streicheln inbegriffen
und ab und zu einen Katheter.
Aber vor dem Gehen
gibt es noch etwas zu regeln.
Also, ich schulde noch Geld.
700 Fr. Anzahlung -
das hat Michel noch gefehlt.
Unglaublich!
* Michel lacht. *
So als Hundebesitzer ...
- Ja.
Sie ziehen einem das Geld aus dem
Sack, bei 2'000 Fr. Rente im Monat!
Das weiss ich nicht.
Ah, Sie wissen es auch nicht.
Ich verstehe es auch nicht.
In der Schweiz ist es
bei der Tierpflege diskriminierend.
Man weiss genau, dass Haustiere
für ältere Leute wichtig sind.
Aber wie sollen solche Leute diese
Rechnungen bezahlen?
Unglaublich!
Niemand hilft ihnen.
Wissen Sie, was ein Tierarzt
einmal zu mir gesagt hat?
Wenn man als Halter kein Geld hat,
dann soll man
auch keinen Hund haben.
Das ist eben nichts anderes als
ein Geschäft, wie jedes andere auch,
das Gewinn bringt.
Michel hat Alix
ziemlich unter Druck gesetzt.
Sie muss nun herausfinden,
woher Olives Herzprobleme kommen.
Als erstes gibt es einen
Ultraschalluntersuch des Herzen.
Der Kardiologe sagt es klar:
Das Problem ist nicht das Herz,
sondern die Lunge.
Er fand heraus, dass
auf der Lunge ein starker Druck ist.
Darum glaubt er
an eine Lungenkrankheit,
die beim Hund
zu einem Herzproblem wird.
D.h., das Herz muss so stark pumpen,
um der Lunge genug Blut zuzuführen,
dass es
zu einer Herzinsuffizienz kommt.
Während Olive beruhigt wird,
schaut der Kardiologe die Flüssigkeit
im Bauchraum genauer an.
Und schau her!
Oh, ich würde sagen,
dass ihr die Atmung
sicher 20 % besser hinkriegt,
wenn ihr hier, ich schätze mal
2 l herausnehmt.
Habt ihr Zeit und Leute dafür?
- Ja.
Eine Weisung des Spezialisten
wird diskussionslos durchgeführt.
Olive kommt also
wieder in die Notaufnahme.
Alix pumpt die Flüssigkeit ab,
die ihm das Atmen so schwer macht.
Jetzt ist Olive
doch etwas eingeschüchtert.
Mit grossen Spritzen entleert Alix
Olives Bauch und überlegt sich,
wo das Problem liegen könnte
und kommt auf eine Idee.
Man weiss, dass es in der Schweiz
viele Parasiten gibt,
die in die Lunge von Hunden
gelangen.
Darum wollen wir
zuerst das abchecken.
Für den Test braucht es noch
eine Blutabnahme und dann ist fertig.
Olive kann sich nach all dem Stress
endlich gehen lassen.
Pipi, pipi, pipi, pipi!
Für Alix ist das
die Stunde der Wahrheit.
Wir haben zwei Tests für zwei
verschiedene Parasiten gemacht.
Einer davon ist tatsächlich positiv.
Die Diagnose ist eindeutig:
Canine Angiostrongylose.
Das sind grosse Würmer,
die die Lunge befallen.
Olive hat vermutlich
eine Schnecke gefressen,
typische Wirte für den Parasiten.
Die Wurmmittel, die man in der
Schweiz normalerweise braucht,
nützen gegen diese Hundekrankheit
meistens nichts.
Darum bekommt Olive
sofort seine erste Tablette.
Wenn man nichts macht,
wird es für den Hund
tatsächlich sehr viel schlimmer.
Durch die Herzschwäche bildet sich
im Bauchraum und in der Lunge
immer wieder sehr viel Flüssigkeit.
Im schlimmsten Fall können diese
zwei Faktoren einen Schock auslösen,
der bei diesem Tier
leider zum Tod führen könnte.
Jetzt muss man nur
noch Michel informieren.
Hallo?- Ja, hier Barbarino
vom Tierspital Bern.
Ohne grosse Worte zu machen, sagt ihm
Alix, was sie herausgefunden hat.
Die Behandlung ist nicht ohne Risiko.
Gewisse Hunde reagieren schlecht,
wenn zu viele dieser Würmer
auf einmal sterben.
Aus den toten Würmern
fliesst ein Gift
und das kann im Tier
einen toxischen Schock auslösen.
Der ist in diesem Fall tödlich.
Ein Schock könnte tödlich ein,
wenn myn die Parasiten abtötet.
Er kann also sterben.
Genau, darum müssen wir
beim Vorgehen sehr gut aufpassen.
Jetzt will Alix Michel
mit einer guten Nachricht
wieder etwas aufmuntern.
Wir gaben ihm vor 1 Std. etwas zu
Essen und er hat alles aufgefressen.
Ah, er hat gefressen.
- Ja. Er hat sehr gut gegessen.
Auf dem Bericht hatte er Plus 3,
d.h. einen sehr gesunden Appetit.
Vielen Dank.- Gern geschehen.
Einen schönen Abend.
Gleichfalls, adieu.
Der Herr macht sich
wirklich grosse Sorgen,
aber er überspielt seine Angst
mit Witzen und Sarkasmus und ...
Auf jeden Fall
macht er sich sicher grosse Sorgen.
Ich wette,
dass er jetzt schon auf Google ist.
Olive verbringt die Nacht
auf der Intensivstation.
Dort wird er ständig überwacht.
Würde er schlecht
auf seine Behandlung reagieren,
könnte das fatale Folgen haben.
Hallo, Kätzchen!
Bevor sie nach Hause geht,
schaut Alix noch einmal
nach ihrem kleinen Schützling.
Das Kätzchen ist wegen einem
Rückenwirbelbruch in Behandlung.
Wenn es das überlebt,
fragen wir den Halter,
ob wir ihm einen Namen geben dürfen.
Das Team durfte vom Besitzer
noch einmal zwei Tage anhängen.
Sollte die Katze ihre Hinterpfote
bewegen, könnte man sie noch retten.
Niemand kann sagen,
sie habe ihre Pfote nicht bewegt.
Ich habe es genau gesehen,
wie du sie bewegt hast.
Ich träume doch nicht.
Sie hat sie bewegt.- Ja.
Das ist nicht, weil ich hier ziehe.
Einen Moment war es besser.
Sie hat selber uriniert
und sich bewegt.
Man darf sie
doch nicht einschläfern!
Ich träume doch nicht,
dass sie das Pfötchen bewegt.
Also, ich träume nicht.
- Nein.
Ah, danke!
Seit drei Tagen glaubt mir niemand.
Schau, jetzt
hebt es sie ganz alleine.- Ah, ja.
Vielleicht kommt das wieder.- Ich
bin sicher, dass sie es bewegt.
Jetzt legt sie es ab,
also hat sie es hochgehoben.
Alix hat wieder Hoffnung.
Er hat sich bewegt.
* Vogelgezwitscher *
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
In der Waadt
begleiten wir Florence zu Fabian,
der in der Nähe von Payerne
seinen Hof hat.
Diesen hat er vor vier Jahren
von den Eltern übernommen.
Vorher hat er schon ein paar Jahre
zusammen mit dem Vater gearbeitet.
Guten Morgen!
- Guten Morgen. Alles klar?- Danke.
Gehen wir gleich zu der Kuh,
die Fieber hat?- Ja.
Am Montag haben wir gemerkt,
dass sie fast nichts mehr frisst.
Und v.a. gibt sie kaum noch Milch:
Vorher gab sie ... äh ...
24 l pro Tag,
jetzt sind es noch 2 l.
Sie frisst und widerkaut nicht mehr.
Nach einer Behandlung am Montag
ist das Fieber gesunken.
Aller klar.
Dann schaue ich sie mir an.
39,5 -
also Fieber hat sie immer noch.
Das Fieber ist nicht gesunken, darum
vermute ich, dass es infektiös ist.
Ich habe auch eine
erhöhte Herzfrequenz festgestellt.
D.h., dass die Kuh
relativ starke Schmerzen hat.
Fabian weiss,
dass seine Kuh Schmerzen hat.
Und er könnte sich auch vorstellen,
warum.
Es könnte ein Fremdkörper sein.
Ich habe nämlich im Futterstroh
ein Stück einer 1.-August-Rakete
gefunden. - Okay.
Ich habe ein Stück
einer 1.-August-Rakete gefunden.
Ich denke,
es ist im Magen steckengeblieben.
Das würde zu den anderen Sachen
passen, die wir gefunden haben:
schlecht verdauter Kot,
der Pansen, der sich nicht dreht.
Für Fabian wäre das nichts Neues.
Seine Wiesen bei Payerne
reichen z.T. bis zum Strassenrand.
Darum muss er
beim Mähen sehr aufpassen.
Ich finde immer wieder Abfall im
Gras, der sehr gefährlich sein kann.
Es gibt Leute, die werfen
Aluminiumdosen zum Fenster hinaus,
dann kommen sie mit dem Gras
durch die Häckselmaschine.
Kleinste Aluminiumteilchen
bleiben dann im Magen und Darm.
Und diese Aluminiumteilchen könnten
für Nala schlimme Folgen haben.
Es könnte einen Magenwandriss geben.
Die Fremdkörper könnten aber auch
das Zwerchfell perforieren
und weiter bis zum Herzen wandern.
Das würde
zu irreversiblen Schäden führen.
Florence
macht noch mehr Untersuchungen.
Wenn sie die Kuh
am Rücken hin- und herschüttelt,
kann sie die Schmerzen einschätzen.
Die Tierärztin hat mit der Faust
in den Bauch geschlagen
um zu schauen,
wie die Kuh reagiert.
Wenn ein Metall- oder Plastikteil
im Magen steckt, dann tut das weh.
Sie hat bei jedem Schlag reagiert.
Wir sahen, dass sie
einen Buckel macht und zuckt.
Alles deutet
auf einen Fremdkörper im Magen hin.
Florence holt das Nötige,
um die Kuh zu behandeln.
Es ist zwar keine Frage von Stunden,
aber trotzdem muss man sie
sofort behandeln.
Wenn in den nächsten 24-48 Std.
nichts gemacht würde,
könnte der Fremdkörper im Magen
der Kuh schlimme Schäden anrichten.
Das ist ein Entzündungshemmer.
Und etwas,
das die Verdauung normalisiert.
Fabian beruhigt Nala,
die sich nicht rührt.
Sie hat ein sehr ruhiges Gemüt.
Natürlich hat sie nicht gerne
Spritzen, wie alle anderen auch.
Im Vergleich zu anderen, die
eher wild werden, ist sie sehr lieb.
So, das hätten wir.
Jetzt noch den Magnetstab hinein.
Der Magnetstab
kann den Fremdkörper anziehen.
Das ist eine sehr einfache,
aber effiziente Methode.
Florence führt das Magnet
mit einem langen Stab
durch den Schlund in den Magen ein.
Dort bindet es
alle magnetischen Teilchen an sich,
damit sie die Magenwand
nicht mehr beschädigen können.
Sie bleibt wirklich ruhig.
So, es ist drin.
Oi, oi, o!
Die Teile der 1.-August-Rakete
sollten am Magnet kleben bleiben.
Aber leider bleiben andere Teile,
z.B. die von Aludosen, nicht hängen.
Darum ist es noch nicht gesagt,
dass die Kuh wieder gesund wird.
Kann ich sie wieder losbinden?
- Ja, danke.
Jetzt muss man
einfach Geduld haben und warten.
Hoffentlich
zieht das Magnet die Rakete an.
Und hoffentlich hat Nala
dann keine Schmerzen mehr.
Fabian ist ziemlich optimistisch.
In der Regel reicht die Behandlung
mit dem Magneten.
In zwei Tagen sieht man eine Ver-
änderung und die Kuh frisst wieder.
Der Magnetstab bindet das
eingeklemmte Teil im Magen an sich.
Nach zwei Tagen sollte es
dem Tier wieder besser gehen.
Und so ist es.
Nach ein paar Tagen führt Nala
wieder ein normales Kuhleben.
Das Magnet und die Raketenteile
werden bis zu ihrem Lebensende
in ihrem Magen bleiben.
Florence
fährt zum nächsten Patienten.
Und auf dem Parkplatz des Tierspitals
Bern kommt Michel aus Genf an.
Er holt seinen Hund Olive ab,
der wegen Atembeschwerden
zwei Tage im Spital bleiben musste.
Alix hat schnell
die richtige Diagnose gestellt.
Jetzt
kann der Hund wieder nach Hause.
Wir sind immer froh,
wenn wir wissen, was los ist.
Dann können wir
die beste Therapie verschreiben
und es dauert nicht zu lange.
Dauert es länger,
ist es eine Herausforderung,
wenn der Besitzer alles wissen will.
In den zwei Tagen ohne Olive hat sich
Michel grosse Sorgen gemacht.
Er kann kaum warten,
bis er ihn endlich wieder sieht.
Grüezi!
- Ja, Grüezi!
Salut, Schätzchen!
Hallo du!
Komm zu Papa!
Das Wiedersehen hat er sich
aber etwas anders vorgestellt.
Sie können gleich mitkommen.
Du bist hier ja völlig verloren.
Er sieht richtig beduselt aus.
Nicht wahr,
du verstehst nichts mehr.
Wahrscheinlich
haben sie ihn betäubt
oder mit Medikamenten vollgestopft.
Ich bin schon froh,
aber er ist völlig apathisch.
Ja, du Schätzchen!
Er hat einfach keine Energie.
So schlapp wie ich ihn abgegeben
habe, kommt er wieder zurück.
Bevor der Hund
wieder zu Kräften kommt,
muss er viele Medikamente nehmen.
Eines davon
bringt Michel zum Staunen.
Hier haben wir ...
- Da steht ja Viagra!
Ihr gebt ihm Viagra, wieso?
Das müssen Sie mir erklären.
* Alle sprechen durcheinander. *
Ich habe recht gestaunt,
als ich das sah - Viagra.
So ist es: Olive
bekommt die berühmte blaue Pille.
Aber nicht für die Wirkung,
die man bei einem Mann will.
Mit Viagra wird
der Druck auf die Lunge verkleinert.
Das ist eine sehr gute Therapie
für diese Infektion.
Ich musste lachen,
als ich die Schachtel sah.
Zuerst dachte ich, sie hätten
die Schachtel verwechselt.
Heisst das nur so
oder ist das wirklich Viagra?
Das ist Viagra!
Ah, gegen
Bluthochdruck in der Lunge?
Es ist das gleiche Medikament,
aber ... äh ...
Du nimmst eine Pille von Papi!
Gut, kommen Sie gut nach Hause!
- Auf Wiedersehen!- Adieu!
Dann komme ich in einem Monat
wieder.- Ich öffne Ihnen die Türe.
Für Olive ist das Gesundwerden
kein Zuckerschlecken.
Er bekommt noch einmal eine Infektion
und muss noch dreimal ins Spital,
bevor er seine Parasiten los ist.
Aber zuerst einmal trabt er glücklich
neben seinem Herrchen her.
Alix hat bald Feierabend. Zeit für
einen Besuch bei ihrem Schützling.
Wo ist denn mein Kätzchen?
Dieses Mal muss sie
der Wahrheit in die Augen schauen.
Die Katze wird ihre Hinterbeine
nie mehr bewegen können.
Alix hängt so sehr
an dem Kätzchen,
dass sie es selber einschläfern will.
Ich habe geweint, weil
die ganze Situation kompliziert war.
Ich habe sehr viel Zeit
bei dieser Katze verbracht.
Ich hatte sie sehr gerne.
Ich machte noch ein paar Fotos
von ihr und mit ihr gesprochen.
Ich habe ihr erklärt, dass sie nun
ins Katzenparadies kommt.
In diesem Moment muss man schauen,
dass sie möglichst ruhig sind.
Obwohl ich traurig war, versuchte
ich, sie das nicht spüren zu lassen,
denn sie spüren, wie es einem geht.
Ja, ich habe auf jeden Fall
viel mit ihr gesprochen.
Unsere junge Tierärztin denkt
noch einmal zurück an ihren Tag.
An die Patienten, die sie
am Leben behalten konnte und an die,
die es nicht geschafft haben.
Mit all diesen Emotionen
muss man lernen umzugehen,
damit man wieder
gerne zur Arbeit geht.
Nächste Woche geht es weiter
mit unseren Tierärztinnen.
Salut Grosse!
In Estavayer-le-Lac
versucht Eléonore,
die 25-jährige Eselin Romana
zu retten.
Das Tier krümmt sich vor Schmerzen,
aber wehrt sich trotzdem
mit aller Wucht.
Im Tierspital in Bern
kümmert sich Alix um Yuzu,
der von zwei streunenden Hunden
angegriffen wurde
und vielleicht gelähmt bleibt.
Ob sie noch ein normales Katzenleben
führen kann, kann man nicht sagen.
Florence kommt Gerald zu Hilfe.
Eine schwierige Geburt für die Kuh
Kamasutra und für unsere Tierärztin.
Oh!
Der erste Fehler den wir machen,
ist auf die Welt zu kommen.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Liz Lei - 2020